Dunder Mifflin this is Pam Thunder
Mifflin this is Jim
Michael went in there with him too he's
pretty sweet really Michael went in with
him wow but they shouldn't be much
longer now so we'll be vaccinating okay
that's good news
um
uh yeah no I'll let you go okay okay bye
hey Oscar what's up Pam um I just wanted
to let you know that Dwight's gonna be
okay the doctor said there's a really
simple treatment for concussion so he'll
probably even be back at work tomorrow
okay
I just thought you'd want to know that
white you won the raffle no way
do you like it walkie talkies
well the committee to plan parties has
served its purpose
we're going to disband in the name of
Christmas
in the name of Nutcracker Christmas
Angela we've been hearing really great
things about your brownies and we were
hoping you'd consider merging the two
parties
I'm not sure
this is your karaoke machine have
Christmas songs
yeah but we don't have the power cord
oh
I may have seen it somewhere
[Music]
is that this one
yeah oh thanks
we'll go tell everyone
okay
[Music]
Angela
is everything okay
no
I miss him
Dwight no John Denver
okay
it's a good talk wait I'm sorry
it's gone because of me
I would be upset if people knew about us
and so he didn't have an alibi for
Michael
denied him
I still think there's a way you can
explain it to Michael
somehow
bam
I am not like you
walking around in your provocative
outfits saying whatever thought Pops in
your head
yeah that's me
thank you this was helpful
have you seen this parenting yeah this
is CeCe's favorite magazine she loves
the pictures of babies she looks at it
when she's on the potty and she makes
the face have you read it has an adult
member of your family read this
particular issue
I flipped through it so you saw the
article on the importance of taking
frequent walks while you're pregnant
of course yeah
I will be taking a morning walk and an
afternoon walk would you like to join me
that sounds nice great
you have a walking buddy
do
there they are party planning committee
together again
well we all wanted to plan your goodbye
party we thought this would be easier
we thought
it's an experiment the three of us have
all been chairman before so this is the
Dream Team hey
what are you saying
the Dream Team in Meredith
hey in there it's me Pam it's not Dwight
don't think it's Dwight what are you
doing here
will you and Dwight have this weird deal
um he sent me out here to see if you
could postpone are you authorized to do
this yes I have been so authorized
okay
um well tell them that we'll do this
tomorrow night instead
okay wait pam pam
how did he seem you know like did he
seem disappointed
you know there are a lot of guys out
there who would just love and appreciate
it just save it
hey Pam
would you like to go with me to grab a
coffee
really yeah I thought you could use some
fresh air
might be fun okay sure
okay
actually you seem so happy
I bet you wish you were like this all
the time
spring of mine let's call her
Noel
she missed this deadline turning
something into corporate in New York
and this
we'll call him Kurt he drove all the way
to New York and handed it in for her
I don't know I guess he just really
likes her a lot
that's great
yes it is
hello
yeah
I'm having relationship problems
and since you're always having
relationship problems I thought you'd be
able to give me some advice what's wrong
I have this crazy thought that I know is
crazy
that maybe Dwight killed my cat
hmm when I got home sprinkle's body was
in the freezer where Dwight said he left
her
but all my bags of frozen french fries
had been clogged to shreds something's
not right
vets doing an autopsy Angela I'm sorry
did Roy ever kill one of your cats
a dog person
so
what's up me all night what do you mean
by Angela's smoking hot body you're
being gross not from a male perspective
you need to set me up with her I know
she told you that she's looking and
she's totally not responding to my moves
what moves I have moonwalked past
accounting like 10 times I can't believe
that's not working yeah
um
I don't know if I really see you two
together
really well maybe you should look in the
smart part of your brain
she's very religious okay well I come
from a line of wasps so long it leads
back to Moses okay well she takes her
convictions pretty seriously she can be
kind of severe yeah and I punched a hole
in a wall right you did yeah now that I
think about it Angela and Andy might
actually make a good couple
but I couldn't do that to Dwight
or Angela
or Andy
hey Angela
I didn't have your ZIP code oh thanks
it was hand delivered but I did get to
save the date after all
it's not my taste
hey Angela you want to see a picture of
Philip wearing those little booties you
got us
so cute
hey you guys want to see a picture of
Gerald wearing galoshes
he refused to go out in the rain until I
bought these now going out in the rain
is all he wants to do
fog is just like having a baby
[Music]
unless you adopt it of course that is
where we disagree
hey are your little dudes crawling yet
no three-month-old humans don't do that
my Philip is crawling
Angela is such a liar it's maddening
exactly that's just like crate training
all night long all night long well count
yourself lucky wait until you have two
that's two sleep schedules two naps that
don't coincide I mean you'll never sleep
again
no one said you must have two like her
jeans are so important the world just
needs more Pam gym DNA thank you no no
thank you
hahaha
check this out my brother just got a new
sailboat he has no idea what he just got
himself into
there's nothing harder than taking care
of a boat
am I right
unbelievable unbelievable